I need to preface this by saying I'm
probably not getting married but if I
were to get married these guys are
certainly invited to my wedding I don't
know where this puts me in the spectrum
of need to learn life lessons but I'm
just saying I I think them being there
would make the wedding more fun so there
that is
Mike and Dave need wedding dates so this
movie stars Zac Efron and Adam Devine
they play a couple of brothers who are
pretty high-strung and they rile each
other up and they always wreck every
family gathering they ever have so their
parents are like all right you guys are
not going stag to your little sister's
wedding cuz you're gonna ruin it so you
two need wedding dates enter Anna
Kendrick and Aubrey Plaza we're pretty
much the female versions of those two
guys they're like hey we'll make them
think we're nice respectable girls we
get a free trip to Hawaii they group up
and then shenanigans and we have a
comedy now a wedding comedy was part way
through this movie I was like oh it's
kind of like wedding crashers hmm are
you guys kind of ripping off wedding
crashers and I realized that movie came
out over 10 years ago and now I know I'm
old as [ __ ] to its credit though it does
make a wedding crashers joke so it knows
wedding crashers happened that's always
good to be self-aware this movie is very
self-aware this movie made me laugh oh
you just pulled it that way this movie
did what it set out to do which was make
me laugh the people cast in this movie
just play a good pair Efron and Devine
they're good they're just good pairs
they play good brothers you know one of
them deep down to the core is more
responsible than the other one the other
ones just like a complete manchild who's
probably not gonna grow up but they riff
off of each other so well you would
swear to God in real life these two are
actually brothers with Aubrey Plaza and
Anna Kendrick at first I was like I like
Aubrey Plaza's character more because I
feel like she's bringing her friend out
of a rut you know so I just I just
thought she added more to the movie and
then you start seeing like nah REE Plaza
is actually kind of a piece of [ __ ] and
just sage is a bit more of a dick than
Anna Kendrick and a Kendrick deep-down
is actually a nice person or the movie
does a good job at giving everyone
layers so really it's like no one in the
movie is a complete piece of [ __ ] I'm
just saying Anna Kendrick is just a bit
more likable she's just a bit more sweet
which is how it should be I mean the
females in this movie should
have that friendship and the males in
the movie should have their friendship
man just everyone was paired up
perfectly and the shenanigans that
ensued in this movie made me laugh
grandi the movies not breaking any new
ground I feel like if there's one gripe
that you're gonna hear in every review
that's holding the movie back I feel
like it's gonna be the thing where it's
like well there's no real new ground in
this movie I feel you can watch the
trailer and be like oh the movies going
to go from here to there and it will
fact if you watch the scene by scene
it's gonna be like the next scene is
gonna be this it will the next scene is
gonna be this it will granite there are
a couple of jokes that you don't see
coming in the sense that it's funny
until the movie kind of takes it
awkwardly too far I'm not saying too far
whatever you gotta do you too far have
for shape no I don't care about that
[ __ ] I'm just saying contextually in the
movie the movie took it a little farther
than it needed to given the movie you're
just a bit like that okay one step over
the line yeah go for it all right you're
gonna put that foot over that you did
you put that foot right over that line
in a way that I can just say made the
joke a little more awkward than it would
have been had you stopped a second and a
half prior guys in the end this movie is
a simple movie that gets a simple reveal
the movie had good pairings in a movie
that doesn't break any new ground but
does admittedly make you laugh in the
end I will say Mike and Dave need
wedding dates is a funny time no alcohol
required alright guys so Mike and Dave
need wedding dates have you seen it what
did you think about it or with your
favorite comedy of 2016 so far whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more